Please welcome Captain Sarah Kociuba.
Captain! Wow!
(audience applauds)
Hi, thanks for having me.
I'm very excited to be here.
I can't, like, how did it feel
when you got the phone call of,
we would like you to be the first of a first
of a first to fly the bomber in the lead at the Super Bowl?
Yes, it was very humbling and very exciting.
So, we have a very strong group
of B-2 instructor pilots here at Whiteman Air Force Base.
So, to be chosen just within that elite group
was very exciting and humbling.
And then, you know, on the actual flyover day itself,
on Sunday, as I stepped to my aircraft, you know,
the entire team was there supporting us,
getting the jet ready to go.
So the entire maintenance team and support team,
and I just felt such a great amount of pride
to be representing that entire team.
And then the entire global strike team as well,
leading both the other two aircraft.
That's so cool.
And you think, 500 missions you've done in combat.
This is very different, right?
So when you're flying over the big game,
what's going through your mind?
Are you looking down to see if you can spot Tom Brady?
What are you looking for?
Admittedly, no, I was not looking for Tom Brady.
Maybe Mahomes, but -
Girl, I understand.
That's right, you're a big Kansas City Chiefs fan.
Yeah. That's our home team here, absolutely.
That's right.
So, we were supporting them, but yeah,
so really focus up until the last few seconds.
Obviously, I was excited, but we were really focusing
on maintaining that tight formation and to make sure
that we were going to be on time.
But then in those last 10 seconds,
my ground controller keyed the mic
so we could really fine tune our timing.
So I was able to hear the last few seconds
of the National Anthem, and I have never felt such pride.
And it was really the pinnacle for my passion of flying
and, you know, my passion for America.
And I felt like as we were pushing the throttles up there
in the last 10 seconds, that I was just saying,
this is for you, America.
And then we flew over and I, it was just very exciting.
Now, Sarah, why does it look like
you're in Batman's plane,
and the one to your left
is like a Delta flight on its way to Vegas?
Yeah, I know, totally.
You're totally right.
Yeah, what's that about?
Yeah, so, the aircraft on our left is the B-52,
and that is our workhorse bomber.
She's been around for a long time.
She's our reliable bomber there, but yeah,
we've got the stealth in the lead, the B-1 -
Yeah, there you go.
Drop the mic.
That's you.
Do you have any advice, you know, right now for,
I don't know, any woman who, like,
may be stressing, out there in the world?
Yeah, absolutely.
So, everybody gets stressed, right.
But it's kind of two-fold how I manage my stress.
My sister is actually a neuropsychologist,
so she has really hammered home
the importance of mindfulness in the day to day.
So I try to practice that as much as I can
and remind myself it's important,
but really in the execution phase, I maintain my calm,
just because of all the extensive training we do.
So, whether it's in the simulator or flying or studying
or mission prepping and briefing,
we are constantly training.
So, when I step to that aircraft and take off,
I really fall back on all the training that I have
because, you know, we got to make decisions on the fly
and we're going very fast.
Decisions need to come in very fast.
So, I just really fall back on that training.
Could I ever come get in the simulator sometime
to see what it's like?
Yeah, absolutely.
Come out to Whiteman.
We'll be, I will personally give you guys a tour
of the jet and the simulator.
Come on over.
Okay. Thank you.
Oh my God.
Do you wanna go?
Can I, I want to come.
Yeah, you can come.
Okay. And I'll, like -
It's a little bit of security prep
that we'll have to do beforehand, but -
Am I correct in this, Sarah that you,
when you were little, you went to Super Bowls
and saw the planes fly over?
Close. Yeah.
So my parents, I grew up in Cleveland,
and they took us to the Cleveland Air Show
pretty much every year.
So, I got to see not only the static aircraft there,
but all the aircraft fly,
and that's kind of where my passion kicked in,
just seeing the aircraft, hearing them, feeling it.
And then when I was 11,
my sister was marching in the Rose Bowl Parade,
so my parents took us out there.
So, yeah.
That was it.
Right when the parade starts, the B-2 does its fly over,
and I had never seen anything like that in my life,
and I just thought it was the coolest thing as a kid.
And it really stuck with me for the rest of my life.
What do you say to little girls
who may have the same dreams that you did
and wanted to fly a plane one day?
To any little girl or little boy out there
that wants to fly, think aviation is cool,
maybe has a passion for it, to just go chase your dreams.
You know, we live in this great country
where we're afforded the opportunity to go chase our dreams.
So, go check it out.
Get into the world of aviation. See if you like it.
And you know, most importantly,
don't let anybody out there convince you
that you can't do it.
You are living proof of that.
Thank you, Captain Sarah Kociuba.
I am just so honored to meet you.
Me, too. It's very exciting.
Thank you! This is so awesome!
(upbeat music)